[Applaudissements]
françois legault ne cachait pas son
enthousiasme au moment de présenter sa
nouvelle candidate dans chutes de la
chaudière et martins une femme de tête
une femme de coeur parce qu'elle va
faire sa marque en politique
après plus de 30 ans en journalisme
martin biron faisceaux en politique
celle qui occupait un rôle d'analyste à
radio canada explique que sa décision a
été prise récemment durant ces vacances
son impartialité journalistique
assure-t-elle n'a jamais été compromise
je sais que j'ai fait les choses
correctement les tic j'ai bâti ma
carrière sur l'éthique fiche peut pas
sortir avec un manque d'éthique martin
biron reconnaît que les nombreuses
candidatures de journalistes en vue des
prochaines élections soulève des
questions légitimes au sein de la
population
il ya peut-être une conversation à avoir
puissions nous y sommes enfin plaisir de
collaborer mais le premier défi de la
candidate vedette sera de convaincre les
électeurs qu'elle est puis le projet de
troisième lien dans la région de québec
comme analyste martin biron dénonçait le
peu d'études démontrant la pertinence de
l ouvrage elle se dit maintenant
convaincu de sa nécessité qui convient
québec 6 après un troisième vient par le
passé martin biron a aussi eu des mots
durs envers certains élus de la cac à la
fin de la dernière session elle
n'hésitait pas à souligner l'arrogance
de la vice-première ministre qui parlait
de geneviève guilbault de son arrogance
de sa grosse tête mais en même temps
j'ai déjà dit que cette filet et est
surdoué moi je lui en tient pas rigueur
je comprends le travail que vous avez à
faire la principale intéressée jure
avoir passé l'épongé mais brillait par
son absence aux côtés de la nouvelle
recrue mais certaines mains je lui donne
sa chance quand on a besoin d'un
troisième union alors ça va dépendre
comment est-ce qu'ils vont s'ouvrir le
dessus sur la rive-sud les et puis pour
le tunnel québec lévis frise les 60 5 %
et le parti conservateur compte bien
marteler que la nouvelle candidate
vedette n'est pas véritablement en
faveur du projet ne les croyait plus ces
gens là vous mentent le ton est donné
pour la campagne ici olivier lemieux
radio canada lévy